Speaker 1: I want we have not talked
about Jordan Peterson for a while,
but he is back on the sort of
speaking trail. And our colleague John
sent me this clip from Jordan Peterson at
Stanford University a few days ago. This was
on I guess it was a couple of weeks ago. This
was a sort of an event on classical liberalism
at the Graduate School of Business at Stanford
University. And. I don't even know how to
explain this. Jordan Peterson started weeping
because he's so upset about climate activism,
not climate change. He's not upset because of
climate change. He's upset because of climate
activism. And he seems unstable, completely
unhinged, really seems to have lost it. I'm going
to play a couple of minutes because you've got to
see the lead up and the lead up as he finds it so
upsetting that sometimes people are negative
about the outlook of the planet and humanity.
And he says that the problem is that people
are being people are getting depressed because
of climate activists. Okay, check this out.
Speaker 2: Don't even have any children. It's
like, no, there's no excuse for that. There
is zero excuse for that. I saw a professor at
an event, something like this. He came out and
trumpeted this bloody, environmentally friendly
house he built. And, you know, fair enough, man.
It was a it was a pretty interesting house, but
not everybody had the $4 million that it took
him to build it. And I'm not criticizing his
money even. It's like he's had some money.
Good for him. He built the house. Okay.
But then to trumpet that as a moral virtue. Well,
you're pushing it there. And then he came out at
all the kids and he said, you know, my wife and I
decided that we were only going to have one child.
And I think that's one of the most ethical things
we could have possibly done. And I would strongly
encourage you to do the same. I thought, you son
of a bitch, you get up in front of these young
people. A lot of these kids were children
of first generation immigrants from China.
And he showed all these images, you know, of these
terrible factories in China, these endless rows of
sterile mechanism that were subordinating
all the Chinese people to this terrible,
you know, capitalist machine. And I thought, if.
Speaker 1: You're still following this.
It's about to get really weird.
Speaker 2: I don't understand. Half
the audience is looking at those factories
and thinking, That's a hell of a lot better
than struggling through the mud under Mao, Buddy.
And so I don't know where he thought he was,
but to come out in front of all those kids
and basically tell them that the whole human
enterprise is so goddamn corrupt, that the
best thing they could possibly do is limit
their multiplication and to think of himself
as a scholar and an educator. It was just
I did say something, by the way. It was rather
uncomfortable. And he stomped off the stage.
But that's no message for young people. That's no
there's no excuse for that. And you think, well,
you know, we're going to destroy the planet.
We have to do this. We have to demoralize
the youth to be ethical. It's like, yeah,
really, that's your theory. You're going to
demoralize young people to be ethical. That's
your theory. It's like you should go home and
think about that for like a year. And I'm
passionate about this, you know, because.
You have no idea how many people that's killing.
You have no idea. I see people everywhere,
all over the world are so demoralized,
especially. Young people, especially young people
with a conscience because they've been told since
they were little that there's nothing to
them but corruption and power. It's like,
how the hell do you expect them to react?
Speaker 1: So this is bizarre. Obviously,
there's a real difference between young people
are told that you are made up of corruption and
and whatever. And, hey, we have some hard problems
that we're facing and they need to be solved. And
you might make a choice. I mean, there's an entire
movement, I think it's called the antenatal list,
which basically says like, we can't bring people.
We should all everybody should stop reproducing
because we are rapidly heading towards a lack
of sustainability and on and on and on. Now,
I happen to disagree with that. I think the way
we solve our problems is actually by reproducing
and creating people that are going to solve
these problems. That's that's my view because I
guess I'm more optimistic than pessimistic. But
this whole thing weeping because people learn
that things are looking so good in some senses
that it would be immoral to hide everyone from
that. Now I'm with you. We don't want to
demoralize people. No, we want to say, hey,
we look at all these problems humanity has solved.
And then here are the problems now facing us and
let's solve them. But I would be crying over
how we're destroying the planet, not about how
kids might find it upsetting that we're destroying
the planet. That seems very, very backwards. And
another one of these really weird, weepy, he just
he seems emotionally disregulated is what that
seems like. And also sort of wrong on the facts
if you can be both at once, which clearly you can.